we're giving you a sneak preview because
we start at 10 o'clock you can watch it
live on Sky News and we've got a a big
audience with us here today as well yes
it's Big Ideas live 22 the big question
who owns the future so many questions
within that we're going to be discussing
throughout the day I'm here on the
future stage with a couple of stages
here today hosting panels of the biggest
innovators and expert thinkers in
science and technology from up and down
the UK now the future stage a lot of
that technology on display here let me
give you a sneak peek we've got
everything from how 3D printing is being
used in fashion it's a machine over here
that prints 3D organs for surgeons to
practice on a little bit out of the area
of my expertise a bit more My Level
though a fitness mirror obviously this
lady here on the mirror is doing a lot
more Fitness than the rest of us are
doing this is what it looks like look at
this
dating VR virtual dating this is just
some of the technology being pioneered
here in the UK that we're going to be
exploring today it is about how the UK
can become the Science and Technology
superpower the government have talked
about now you'll see it on Thursday in
the budget the chancellor Jeremy Hunt at
ring fencing the pledges for research
and development in the UK to push it
towards that Aid and to protect the
increase they promised by 2025. it's
something we're going to be discussing
here today